[Musik]
na klar
herzlich kommt sondern wie heute wir
begeben uns heute auf die spuren der
deutschen jugendsprache von heute denn
wir werden uns heute mal die original
szenen von martha walter kkh schaller
einfach die hübsche anschauen ich hatte
vor einigen tagen schon mal video dazu
gemacht aber in diesem video haben ganz
essenzielle szenen gefehlt unter anderem
die szene selbst in der sie das sagt und
wir alle stellen uns die frage der ethik
diese frau eigentlich werden jetzt
beantworten und ja wir legen einfach los
die folge die strengsten eltern der welt
mutter als persönlicher sklave letzte
berlin neukölln im problemviertel der
hauptstadt liegt die 17 jährige martha
walczak das ist es direkt ist fängt
direkt damit an also das ist über die
strengsten eltern der welt immer so eine
doppelfolge dass zwei leute vorgestellt
werden der eines fabian er ist natürlich
komplett irrelevant für uns wir wollen
einfach nur marta in action sehen und ja
wir machen können sie schon mal bereit
machen jetzt gleich kommt die szene
die queen hat keinen schulabschluss
dafür aber ein selbstbewusstsein wie ein
supermodel das erfüllt mich schon ein
bisschen mit mit stolz zeitgleich mit
dieser person in diesem land zu leben
naja ohne witz das ist schon das ist
schon ein comic moment ne also die
topleute dieser spruch ist sowas von in
die jugendsprache eingang des möchte ja
selbst in einem eigenen freundeskreis ne
das ist das ist deutsch das ist deutsch
das ist deutsche sprache geworden so die
17 jährige hatte in ihrem leben noch
nichts erreicht
das kann man so nicht sagen also gut ich
mein kein mensch denkt sich so ja die
korrekte personen so aber sie hat die
deutsche sprache so geprägt richtig
krass geprägt wie diesen klagen antoine
die sonst geprägt hat das muss man sich
einfach mal vor augen halten also ich
finde es überall wieso die mimik sender
in deutschland in letzten jahren
hochgekommen ist eigentlich im letzten
jahr in den letzten monaten ist das so
viel passiert so you look punkt echse
die so gut und so viele geile
youtube-kanäle die geilen content machen
sich flugs rauskommen
ich will alles dafür tun einfach party
man kann es geschafft die ist ein
statiker new york wer wer ist auf diesem
level installiere denke jetzt wichtiger
was der von euch heiße aber denk mal
wirklich darüber nach wer ist auf diesem
level so ein star dass er in deutschland
so bekannt ist und so viele leute
einfach einen kennen und die sprüche von
einem benutzten das beste was ich machen
konnte tanzen muss aber kurz über sie
als person reden nicht nur über das mini
ganze zeit die ist schon ist schon
geisteskrank klaus das beste was sie
machen kann es party und tanzen mussten
wir so ein bewerbungsgespräch draußen ja
also frau war ja jetzt war am ende
unseres bewerbungsgespräch angekommen
fassen sie doch kurz noch mal zusammen
wo ihre persönlichen stärken am ersten
ligen party tanzen um ihren lebensstil
zu finanzieren besteht sie regelmäßig
die eigene mutter also ist wirklich eine
gute mischung aus lachen und weinen
sogar in folge einerseits denkt und sich
so mal wieder wie bei ist immer bei die
strengsten eltern der welt ist was ist
das für eine göre
was für ein kind aber andererseits ich
weiß ich kann ich kann die nicht so ich
kann dir irgendwie nicht so hopps nehmen
wie die anderen die in den folgen von
die strengsten eltern der welt weil die
ist wirklich dass das deutsche kultur
geworden
sie waren mit klinker mit alaba sie habe
ihr klar vielleicht zu hause ich hab
alles genommen alles kennen die das
wissen wir auch warum marschall also sie
töten araber gang das ist schon
deprimierend also lasst uns sagen wir
wissen darauf ein leute müsst euch
vorstellen dass das ist aber tochter
okay der ihr müsst alles in einem
haushalt einfach festschrauben mit
schrauben in die wand rein ballern weil
sonst die raben tochter das einfach
mitnimmt mascha einfach die kriminelle
jetzt schon mal hauptstraße diebstahl
ja körperverletzung da muss ich
aufpassen was ich sage sie wurde sie
wurde schon ich zitiere vor gestraft
nicht vorbestraft das halt jetzt denken
sie mal vorbestraften strafe diesen ein
ford gestraft das ist was das wort und
den status den gibt es nur in der welt
von martha welsch hat ganz andere
ihre mutter ist der 17 jährigen völlig
egal new york not da müssen jetzt mal
sogar edelight okay jetzt mal unter uns
was für eine frechheit von ihrer eigenen
mutter
was fällt dir ein was denken sie wer sie
ist eine erziehungspersonen format oder
so ist er vollkommen absurd martha tut
ihr auch noch den gefallen okay sie
schlägt ja nicht mehr hat sie nicht mal
zusammengeschlagen
sie ist einfach an ihrer handtasche
gegangen und hat geld raus geklaut und
die mutter so gibt es geld zurück
[Gelächter]
ganz denn das also nicht mal sagen ich
will nichts falsches sagen aber kennt
ihr diesen alten ausdruck leute altes
sprichwort wurde mir als kind immer
gesagt wenn ich ja nicht nicht so ganz
geschickt habe was ich da gerade sagen
wer im glashaus sitzt sollte nicht mit
steinen werfen
martha sitzt im glashaus und stieß mit
dem katapult
während du bist schieße bgl komma klar
der bullen sind attac oder sinnlosem
bullen vorbei gefahren leute jetzt hat
die der gail packen müssen
also sorry so krass undankbar und dumm
kann man wirklich nicht sein aber ohne
wird sich liebe dich für mascha einfach
die hübsche ich die wirklich dafür gilt
dass der spruch ist geil
wie kann man seine eigene mutter dafür
wissen dass sie alt ist es ist einfach
schockierend und entsetzlich könnte so
viel schärfer schießen das ist jetzt
gerade machen aber ich mache das man
nicht weil gehört sich nicht aber wir
schauen uns einfach an wie sie grazie
wie eine elfe elefant auf ihren hohen
schuhen davon stolziert nachdem sich
ihre eigene mutter hohe genannt hat das
ist wirklich ein ganz großes kino
ich habe keine kraft
die mutter tut mir wirklich leid alter
das kommt jetzt direkt nachdem ich mich
über machen so bisschen lustig gemacht
habe aber naja das kann doch nicht sein
oder auch die eigene mutter mit so
gezielten beleidigungen so zum beiden zu
bringen
das ist schon eine heftige nummer findet
in berlin-neukölln denkt matthias mutter
anna wehmütig an die zeit als sie ihre
tochter noch das nette kleine mädchen
war immer wieder sucht die
alleinerziehende polin die ursache für
den wandel ich muss an der stelle auch
wenn es jetzt schwer ist dem kontext
noch mal das sagen was ich auch sonst
immer sagen weil die strengsten eltern
der welt wenn ein kind so krass
fehlschlägt so krass über die stränge
schlägt sind eigentlich fast immer die
eltern auch mit schuld muss man in der
situation sagen ich weiß dass krass wenn
man das jetzt so sieht hier und sieht
was sie sich raus nimmt gegenüber ihrer
eigenen mutter und biete die bereit und
so wie es die mutter fertig macht aber
die eltern sind da fast immer mit schuld
weil sie ihrem kind zum beispiel keine
grenzen aufgezeigt haben besser war so
punkt ich mag man hier ich habe alles
gegeben war nicht kann was ich kann ich
gebe
aber mehr ich können sie es geht auch
wirklich beides gleichzeitig also
einerseits kann man sagen das ist sicher
irgendwas schief gelaufen aber
andererseits tut mir die frau auch leid
so also so wie sie spricht leute dass
man darüber reden ist die wahrscheinlich
vielleicht in erster generation so nach
deutschland gekommen war vielleicht in
polen ist nach deutschland gekommen hat
sich ihr neues leben aufgebaut so dass
ist natürlich das eine besondere
umstände so das ist natürlich schwerer
dann auch in kind richtig zu erziehen
wenn du keine komplett fremden land bist
du gar nicht weiß was abgeht oder der
vater von martha wohl jetzt auch gar
nicht gezeigt dass wahrscheinlich auf
abgehauen so schlecht am flughafen
treffen martha und fabian zum ersten mal
aufeinander
sie sind die einzigen alleinreisenden
jugendlichen am flughafen und schauen
gezielt aneinander vorbei direkt weiter
leute dann auch noch starallüren beim
beim dreh ok also es ist so dass ich am
flughafen sollte irgendwo hinfliegen
marta oder fabian die also verwendest
der andere der mit einer folge mit dabei
ist denken sich natürlich dass sie jetzt
nach ibiza fliegen in ihrem leicht
verkehren weltbild weil man scheinbar
für eigene mutter beleidigen kuren und
psychisch fertig machen ein ibiza urlaub
geschenkt bekommt das ist also in deinem
kopf 200a superzicke martha später
schüchterne mädchen das von sich aus
keine jungs anspricht und fabian will
auch nicht den ersten schritt auf sie
machen
diesen stil nicht aber so drei meter an
ihm vorbei gelaufen so wie weit war dass
gerade kann man ja dass wir sind doch
sie sind die einzigen der einreisenden
jugendlichen am flughafen dessen 5 meter
und hier super zicke martha später
schüchterne mädchen da sind so drei
meter es waren wieder faxen alter wie
jetzt kommt na klar da ihr werdet jetzt
ins land geschickt ritus und nicht wahr
sein mäßig fans ist das richtige gulag
geschickt er werde jetzt richtig
auseinandergenommen
dies habe auch mit dem star alle unsere
flughafen nicht ich weiß dass sie auch
in die formel 1 gehört aber sie muss
mich ansprechen
marta hatte so ihre prinzipien
sie hat feste ansichten wer zuerst auf
ihn zugeht jörg leute was dachtet ihr
denn her komplett krank dass sie dir
martha spricht irgendwelche jungs an was
masala die hübsche jungs anspricht gibt
ihr einfach diese ausstellung das boz
level die spricht keiner der jungs an
was soll man sagen sollte ich bin
dankbar in dieser zeit leben zu dürfen
ganz wichtig jetzt für euch wenn ihr
nicht wollt dass martha wirtschaft zu
euch kommt und euch dazu bringt dass ihr
euch für euer alter schämt dann
abonniert jemanden kanal checke ich
vorgeschlagen das video ab ich will an
der stelle masala einfach raus macht's
gut
du bist